[Musik]
ihr kennt alle mit sicherheit türkische
manta das sind ärzte keine typische ganz
kleine taschen gefüllt mit hackfleisch
muss jetzt ganz neu ist das habe ich
gemerkt würde ich den islam
zuletzt ist er nicht auf kritisierte man
deshalb frittierte türkische mini
maultaschen von die bestell ich mir
[Musik]
darunter geflohen jetzt aber
war
richtig geil geführt oder sogar geführt
da können wir eigentlich nur die
arabische variante geschmack wo die
räder kommt auch so ein bisschen
arabischen dass ich finde generell nicht
viel ist nach erwischen touch bekommen
sehr lecker aber so klasse stehtisch
sind auf jeden fall viel dünger gerollt
jak
sind schiffchen wieder schiffchen
[Musik]
aber im endeffekt nur kleine teigtaschen
alles relativ harte teigtasche
die einfach nur mit joghurt wird
schwimmen oder das hätte potenzial und
ich glaube postel und den tag richtig
schön weichen bekommen ein bisschen
keine ausläuft die kleine machtkämpfe
das ist dann ganz so dass besucher
janecek
[Musik]
frischer kraft persönlich mag die mit
halb orangensaft und halb
granatapfelsaft schließlich ganz so
sauer aber nidda frisch und so sehr sehr
lecker kriegt ihr auch dass überall mit
prisma frisch bei euren augen
hammer
[Musik]
sie mit mit nutella und dann wird das
hier noch warm gemacht
[Musik]
wir sind am galata turm das bedeutet in
san sebastian cheesecake indiana bietet
das café wo bis arbeit allererstes von
guten halben jahr probiert haben und ich
habe jetzt schon dreimal in san
sebastian chips gegessen hatte ich hier
bin und erwarten mit dreimal nüchterner
prozent gelegen er wird uns
hundertprozentig schmeckt wenn er so
schmecken von einem halben jahr und die
nichts geändert an der rezeptur und
suchen uns auch in meinen videos genauso
sehen natürlich auch andere sachen aber
beliebt
[Musik]
das definitiv nicht sagen ich weiß alles
stinkt aber bei mir weil man die vanille
so raus schmeckt und hat sich so es in
der saison so wie ich dann wenn ich der
glücklichste mensch der welt
ok er schnitt sich funktionsträger
angenommen
eine andere frage wie schmeckt sehr
braun die mit der weiße schokolade es so
krass ich bin einfach nicht so viel ich
hier sondern ganz zuversichtlich und
sieht mich an und sagt ich war echt noch
unbekannt und ich hoffe 2.0 mit jungen
mann dann verspeisen geräte und wirkung
[Musik]
so cool aus
einfach so eine masse ausweist und rohem
fleisch aber große schritte gar nicht
mehr dass auch komplett ohne fleisch so
schlimm die gabel
mit ihm gingen
ja gut möglich so schmeckt wie käse und
schinken zusammen das ist china mit
chipkarte das lawa sport mit ski kräfte
hier ganz typisch kanada für zero dann
haben wir für alle die es doch mit
fleisch mögen einfach ein fleisch mantel
drumherum die haben wir so eine art
sowie lieber im sushi allerdings ist es
kein sushi blatt sondern er sagte mir
weintrauben blätter und das ist quasi
inside out also hier haben wir draußen
die g-kräfte maschinen salat und dann
dazwischen noch nicht so genau kann ab
wie sirup ok sojasauce
ich bin richtig gut
das ist schöner käse und schicken lassen
oder auf jeden fall eines besseren
belehrt
[Musik]
steht sie vor der bibliothek wie hier
soll der erste von cheesecake von
natürlich auch spanien in istanbul
gekommen sein das heißt also eigentlich
können die kids dem besitzer vom niblock
weltkrieg auf das stimmt hier könnten
wenn man die kommentare schreibt wir da
irgendwas gehört habe darüber auf wie
pfleger voll und wir werden dies auch
mit plus zum probieren jetzt einfach mal
den ich sage mal original san sebastian
schief gehen
wie so viele projekte stecken musste der
laden ist so voll ist mit den ängsten im
café den ich jemals so wie wir es noch
nie so eng beieinander
[Musik]
also viele sollen wirklich der
allererste san sebastian skater in
istanbul aufgetaucht sein ich habe
gerade noch mal in den keller und die
bietet aber hier nicht der schokoladen
so sagen aber den sieg
nämlich aus wir machen jetzt noch
zusammen die geschmacksprobe
das schmeckt in der kreuzung
ausgestreckt und vanilleeis und genau so
hat sich der immer genau
also dieses vanilleeis geschmack
aussuchen wie bei uns begeistert york ab
es ist unser glück im garten
also wenn ich jetzt wie block mit jana
vergleiche dann würde ich immer wieder
zum weblog café gehen weil er also der
sommersession schmeckt hier noch eine
theke software noch ein ticket
aromatischer und erhaltet nicht verrückt
aber ich merke die lieber raus hat ich
will meine schreckliche überaus oder
gedacht weil das war schon mal ein top
label jetzt da ich hier bin ich hier
noch einen ticken besser man lässt sich
das aber auch unbezahlte kostet ein
stück also 23 ihren umgerechnet circa 4
euro
schmeckt auch echt und imbiss mit drei
minuten wartezeit rechnen vielleicht
auch ein bisschen länger sein
und es gibt halt ist sebastian schiek
eine von den proben genommen und wenn
man mal nicht zum großen hund hat dann
nimmt man sich einfach in halb- und hier
gibt es nur den sanft entschlief und
frauen das selbst erneuert und hab ich
euch gesagt also nur den fans sebastian
john boyne sonst kriegt illegal ausser
natürlich getränke aber an sich nichts
anderes
[Musik]
nein
kaffee mit schaukeln als 70 einem
normalen studium schaukeln
[Musik]
also looks sakrament cache mega oder
clips von den ort aber locker bin vorher
zu kommen könnte auch zugrunde
[Musik]
seit dem neunzehnten jahrhundert
der sohn eines konditors gewesen
mittlerweile gibt heute keinen jeder
ecke
der laden ist nicht einfach
aufhalten
er ist persönlich kann die klassiker
kann man sich schon jetzt wenn er damit
unterschiedliche sachen passiert
versagen die vermissten mädchen großer
vorsicht immer ohne es zu wissen von den
berg ist das original
[Musik]
ja
diese diese tatsache
sollten
das menschengroße
die
also wir bekommen wertvolle punkte
[Musik]
ich wollte euch nur sagen was heißt auch
wir schwitzen man kann doch für schützen
also man kann auch die ware mitnehmen
und das verschweißen eine packung
verschweißten dass der metallbox so
läuft dann auch nicht aus dem kopf mit
voll cool eigentlich genial genial
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ein schönes hier oben in der vierten
etage können wir super frühstücken aber
das zeige ich euch jetzt sind die
mission scheinbar aus und man entdeckt
diesen laden erst gar nicht geht einfach
durch diesen laden und dann in aufzug
und war dann ganz
[Musik]
so dass mein blut blog wir hoffen dass
euch gefallen hat waren die kinder auf
der waage jetzt brauche haben darauf
jedenfalls freuen wir uns über feedback
gibt dem video gerne ein bisschen nach
oben abonnieren um seinen kanal
kostenlos wenn wir mehr solcher box
treten und schreibt gerne hier unten
rein kosten und tarife straße gemacht
haben wird diesen jetzt nach deutschland
und bis zu unserem nächsten video
[Musik]